we're here at the Crescent dunes solar
energy project that utilizes molten salt
for energy storage given that the plant
is the first of its kind of this
technology in the world there's an
urgency to get this plant up and running
it's a very exciting opportunity to
bring new technology online the
construction period from first shovel in
the ground to kind of electricity
delivery to the homes is about a 30
month process we have about 600
construction workers on-site all working
very long shifts to complete the process
we've completed all the heavy civil work
and all the pieces are in place
my name is Emily and I'm a resident of
Tonopah Nevada I work out here this
solar reserve and we assemble the
heliostat right now we're standing in
the heliostat assembly area it's similar
to any kind of car assembly plant the
frames come from the back of the shop
and we assemble the mirrors at the front
the final part of the assembly is the
calibration process there are screws in
the backing plate of the heliostat
mirror and these screws are adjusted by
technicians in the assembly process to
bring this calibration of this mirror
into tolerances within a millimeter once
the heliostat is completed the
calibration process it is ruled out of
the building loaded on a trailer and
delivered out to the field behind me
once it meets its position takes
approximately minutes to install
the huge that mirrors have been given
you know fairly rigorous testing ice
hailstorms
when sand dust that sort of thing and
they will go for the life of the plant
the size of the facility really is
dictated by the efficiencies of the edge
of the mirror
you really look at the economics I'm not
building one more ring of mirrors are
you getting enough electricity or enough
energy out of that to justify making it
bigger probably one of the more
significant challenges in building these
power plants they were built in remote
areas so logistics become a big piece of
the puzzle and actually getting the
delivery and a people to the site to
install the equipment how can we do it
more cost-effective than what can we do
on the next project this technology
really is designed for large scale
facilities utility size we do have
scaled-down versions that we're looking
at for large industrials once we go into
commercial operation we will have a
whole new set of lessons learned that
we'll be able to capitalize on to get to
that next facility and continue to get
our cost curve going down to meet future
energy demand
you